[Music]
not your typical Mother's Day weekend as
a car slams right into this home as you
can see the damage that's been left
behind just heard a loud boom while
washing dishes Jared Allen rents this
home in the Maravilla community near and
Road in Decatur when on Saturday
afternoon what he thought was his son
playing upstairs was really a car
crashing into the side of his house as I
looked out of the window I saw you know
three younger black males
running with ski masks and then I
noticed the vehicle was inside of the
garage
flying to burst Southwest Gas responding
quickly my concern was my family my two
boys my pregnant girlfriend you know
especially once I start smelling gas and
I literally had just
finished cooking lunch for my family
fortunately none of his family was hurt
but fellow neighbor Erica Morrison who
lives right around the corner says this
is just another reason why their
Community needs more protection this
would be really nice for you guys here
to let people understand that we really
could use a gate and maybe some speed
bumps because we got little kids I spoke
briefly to the woman who had her car
stolen and while she didn't want to be
on camera she shared with me that she
lives in the neighborhood right across
the street and only had the car for a
couple of months reporting in the
Northwest Valley Madison Kimbrough eight
news now
North Las Vegas Police tell us they're
still looking for the person who did
this